need motivation White's a top-10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
passionate advice from Milly Bobby Brown
to give you the motivation confidence
and belief that you need
okay let's kick it off with real number
one find your true passion how can I
find my passion it has to come with from
within it has to be real has to be
authentic as long as you know you have
those like three main factors you're
gonna find your passion it can be
anything and nothing is ridiculous
nowadays you can actually be anything
you'd like and everybody accepts who you
are because it's 2018 rule number two
always keep learning did you take any
advice or learn anything from them on
set and did you guys feel like you had
to sort of like trap you're pretending
we were taking it I learned it's a
collaboration I learned a lot from them
and they don't really have to speak so I
like I would just watch them and even if
I wasn't in the shots I'd watch of watch
the monitoring and they take it all in
because it's like one of my favorite
things to do is when I'm not on screen
watch the screen and I'd learn a lot so
like every project I'm doing right now
like in my teen years is like it's
important because it's a life experience
and I'm learning new things just about
me as a person
but I'm so sorry for sound but but also
me as a character so it definitely
helped a lot just trying to learn more
about everyone's jobs and and you know
that's all I can do you know I'm 15 I
have so much life ahead of me so right
now I just want to learn and listen to
what people have to say and and learn
about everybody else's jobs on set and
you know if that's me if that's me
helping with the lighting sure I'll do
that too rule number three find your
gift
Meli Bobby Brown I am just in awe when
I'm watching her I think she's a very
special actress Nili has these
incredible instincts I don't know where
they come from but let's just let this
happen and stay out of her way she's
able to convey
more without a word then many actors
convey with monologues tape came in for
Milli that was so spectacular you know I
remember even season one she has lines
but not she has very few lines there was
a concern of oh is 11 coming through it
was 11 kind of pop in the way that we
all want her to we had to rely on her
giving looks that convey a lot of
information a lot of emotion once we
film that first close-up of her that's
when we knew it was something something
special what she does with her eyes
which she does with her face which he
does with a certain glance mushy all of
Elevens power stuff which now that kind
of famous the hands that turn it her
neck this was all all designed by an 11
year old girl rule number 4 embrace who
you are how can I feel more comfortable
in my own skin look at yourself in the
mirror I always do this and I look at
myself in the mirror and I'm always like
oh I'm very obnoxious look at myself
Merryn oh look at yourself in the mirror
and embrace who you are because people
love you forever you're going to be the
true people who love you will love you
for whatever you are so if you're
comfortable in your own skin it doesn't
matter if you're curvy if you're skinny
or whatever you have I will always love
you the way you are and everyone else
you're true people will love you the way
you are too also if you want to learn
from other successful women check out my
254 girlboss series it's free the link
to join is in a description below I have
a tremendous amount of love and
compassion for everyone else I don't
wanna have a label I want to have a
legacy I believe ambition is not a dirty
word it's just believing in yourself
rule number five never give up
I did so I felt like losing it right you
know it's easy doing things with no
health but totally right feeling wrong
rule number six share positive energy I
think it's really important to keep
social media so light-hearted and loved
and I think it's important to show your
goofy side I don't think it needs to be
so I love seeing you doing your homework
the other day now I mean it's real good
I have to do I'm not going to try to
hide that's not cool to not do your
sports so called it if your school oh
you read your slaw and you're getting
your education so yeah I think that it's
you know social media should just be a
light hot place where you show the
person you are and not the person you're
trying to to show you know being cool
because society really it's very much
like trying to be cool especially being
a teenager you just want to feel cool
and different and trendy but really
that's not cool
and what is cool is just being yourself
rule number seven do different projects
I tried everything
[Music]
I would love to be alone today buddy
I got a Princess Leia if they made a
Star Wars right love she's our hero like
that without a minute you know father
you know them or Madison so I think I
was already something that's more soft
it's a hard boy
[Music]
rule number 8 be yourself
my parents always let me be who I want
to be I'm very outspoken very loud very
opinionated and that's why I'm the way I
am really and people accepted me and
some people don't which is you know it's
just the head situation they have to
deal with but either way I think to
raise someone who's gonna be empowering
and influential you have to let them be
who they want to be rule number nine
sees opportunities I was 11 years old
when I auditioned for this show could
one talk
it was a sci-fi thriller that was going
to be made my Netflix so I was extremely
excited I mean the only thing that I
kind of was excited for was the fact
that it was made by Netflix at the time
because I didn't know what the show was
about and then I auditioned for it and
then we actually we Skyped the directors
and I and the pastor dr. Kammen Cuba we
talked about 80s and everything 80s for
maybe an hour or so about you know like
the Goonies or stand by me and all these
different cool eighties movies that we
all loved and adored so we talked about
that and then they asked if I would like
to come to LA Los Angeles and we flew
there and we had spoken about the script
and what I was going to do but I had no
idea that they first of all had to shave
my head second of all that eleven had
powers I mean we had no idea so it was
definitely a close of definitely a shock
and then I went into the screening room
they had you know had me with fin
wolfhard who plays Mike and we
immediately just we clicked our
chemistry was amazing and so the next
day I got the rope and rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is seen
you kicking me out you've got my list no
kidding I can't do you know what's going
out of that beautiful mind I'm on your
magical mystery ride and I'm so dizzy
don't know what hit me but I'll be all
right
[Music]
cuz all of me loves all of you
now I've got a really special bonus rule
from Milly that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
how can you share some positive energy
today number two what are you never
going to give up on and number three
what does be yourself mean to you to
shape to shape all your hair office is
that it's a big statement and I was only
11 years old at the time I was going
into you know my teen years so I was
pretty nervous to not have any hair but
you know I kind of I I didn't really I
didn't think about it's why I say I
immediately wanted to do it because
because I thought that it was it's
important for me to to feel good with
myself no matter what I look like but
when I shave all my hair off the show
hadn't come out yet so nobody really
knew about me and so when I'd go outside
people would laugh at me and and I
remember those this one specific moment
where I was in a Halloween store and I
was buying my buying my Halloween
costume and I had tried it on and I
think I put on a Tinkerbell outfit and I
was only 11 at the time and this grown
couple they started laughing in my face
and pointing at me and making fun of me
but you know I think that I think the
reason it bothered me is because now
people say that it's so cool to shave
your head but is that just because of
who I am like would you have said that
if I was just in the Halloween stuff so
there are moments in time when where I
just I know I know that I looked awesome
with it I didn't really take into
consideration other everybody else's
opinion because everybody else's opinion
could have been faked
if you want to see the top 10 idea done
zendaya check out their video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
confidence is the best I think you can
literally rock a trash bag if you have
confidence and I don't need to custom
whatever I don't need to do that to make
a great song